[Applause]
hey now stephen bring yourself a new
comedy drama series it's called the
outlaws it's on bbc one on the 25th of
october at 9 00 p.m and this is i mean
really your baby i mean you wrote it you
directed it you're in it your hometown
tell us about it yes that's right yes
it's it's a show it's a sort of uh a
comedy drama thriller set in bristol um
yes no you're right to cheer um
are you calling that a cheer
could you beat that up
um well people don't think naturally i
think of bristol as a sort of place for
uh for sort of crime and you know and
stuff but um we were in 2019 and these
guys may know we were voted the cocaine
capital of europe
which we're very proud yeah thank you
yeah we are we're uh is that on a sign
as you cover that's right yeah no well
that's not good we're famous for three
things crack and wallace and gromit
and um
anyway so there is there was always this
kind of there was always like a crime
underbelly when i was growing up in
bristol and my mum was involved with
community service you know if you if you
get a drink driving charge or some minor
crime you have to do community service
um i'm sorry my mom wasn't a criminal
she uh
i think she stole some of those pencils
from argos
but uh she sort of would mind these uh
these offenders and sort of look after
them and supervise them and i always
thought that was an interesting area for
a tv show because you have the most
unlikely groups of people coming
together that wouldn't normally meet
each other so you know she would tell me
about people that would come through her
door and there was i remember there was
an old man that used to steal cabbages
from allotments
and and he would always get caught and
he would keep coming back you know year
after year clearly it doesn't work
because he would always be you know
always doing crimes again and she
figured out eventually that um he was
just he was just lonely and he didn't
have sort of friends and family so he
was sort of stealing to sort of enjoy
the community service experience so
there'd be sort of someone like him like
an old guy like him and then there was a
i'm not joking there was a kid i went to
school with
we'll call him dave
he was coming through the doors
constantly and he would and so and he'd
come in and he'd say hello mrs merchant
you know how steven doing oh he's doing
his a-levels what have you been up to
dave oh you know i was just trying to
chip a banksy off the wall and they
arrested me and i'm doing 120 hours and
and he was i remember i would talk to
her he was the worst he was the laziest
criminal i've ever heard of he he once
he once broke into a house and he was
stealing the tv
and the homeowners came back
and they went dave what are you doing
and he went i'm not dave
and they went yeah you are you live next
door
he was breaking into his own neighbor's
house i would at least go one road over
so my mom would tell me about these
groups of people and i just thought it
was such an unusual like imagine if the
old guy with the cabbages and him were
like talking and what that would be like
and then i thought well they're already
criminals so we could have a kind of
thriller story to it and so we sort of
combine that together and i think
hopefully it's quite a sort of
entertaining you know mixture of sort of
humor and drama and and thriller
[Music]
you